Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. We are recording this in early February 2022, at a time of escalating tensions in Eastern Europe, focused along the border of Russia with Ukraine. And Dominic, it's fascinating, isn't it, if you have any interest in early medieval history, because last summer, Vladimir Putin, or at least someone pretending to be Vladimir Putin, wrote an essay about the historical background to this. 5,000 words, Tom, I think it was.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。我们是在2022年2月上旬录制这期节目的，当时东欧的紧张局势正在不断升级，焦点集中在俄罗斯与乌克兰的边界上。多米尼克，如果你对早期中世纪历史感兴趣的话，这不是很引人入胜吗？因为去年夏天，弗拉基米尔·普京，或者至少是某个假冒弗拉基米尔·普京的人，写了一篇关于这一历史背景的文章。汤姆，我想那篇文章大约有5000字。
5,000 words. And he went back, obviously, through the history of the Soviet Union, back through the emergence of the Russian Empire. But he ended up going all the way back to the 10th century and the emergence of the Kingdom of the Rus. Russians, Ukrainians, and Belarusians, Vladimir Putin, I put that slightly in inverted commas, wrote, are all descendants of ancient Rus, which was the largest state in Europe. Slavic and other tribes across the vast territory were bound together by one language,
5000字。他显然回顾了苏联的历史，一直追溯到俄罗斯帝国的崛起。但他最终一直追溯到了10世纪罗斯王国的兴起。弗拉基米尔·普京（我这里加一点引号）写道，俄罗斯人、乌克兰人和白俄罗斯人都是古代罗斯的后裔，古代罗斯是欧洲最大的国家。这片辽阔领土上的斯拉夫部落和其他部落被单一的语言、
economic ties, the rule of the princes of the Rurik dynasty, and after the baptism of the Rus, the orthodox faith. And I guess two things leap out from that. One is Putin's argument that because there was this great empire, this great kingdom of the Rus, covering a vast expanse of territory, therefore, everybody who lives in lands that constituted that kingdom properly should be part of Russia, I guess, is the kind of implicit argument. And the other argument is, it's one from Silence, where he talks about Slavic and other tribes, but he notably does not mention anyone coming from Scandinavia, which is very much the sense that I have, that the foundations of the Rus kingdom, this kind of emergent kingdom in what becomes Russia and Ukraine were actually Vikings. Well, this is a massively controversial issue, isn't it, Tom? So this week's subject is the Vikings in the East, which is this impossibly kind of romantic, violent, exotic, exciting,
经济纽带、留里克王朝诸侯的统治，以及罗斯受洗后的东正教信仰紧紧联系在一起。我想其中有两点非常显眼。一点是普京的论点：因为曾有过这样一个大帝国、伟大的罗斯王国，它覆盖了广袤的领土，因此，所有生活在构成该王国的土地上的人，按理说都应该成为俄罗斯的一部分，我想，这大概是一种隐含的论点。另一个论点则是基于沉默的论点，他在文中谈到了斯拉夫部落和其他部落，但值得注意的是，他没有提到任何来自斯堪的纳维亚的人——这非常符合我的看法，即罗斯王国的基石，这种在后来成为俄罗斯和乌克兰的土地上新兴王国的基石，实际上是维京人。嗯，这是一个极具争议的话题，不是吗，汤姆？所以本周的主题是东方的维京人，这是一个令人无法抗拒的浪漫、暴力、充满异国情调、刺激
murky subject, but it's also politically very controversial. So in the Soviet Union, there were massive arguments, and there was a sort of a real movement in the Soviet Union, there were massive arguments and there was a sort of a real movement in the Soviet Union to say that basically, okay, there were some Scandinavians, i.e. Vikings there, but they weren't very important and their cultural imprint was soon kind of, you know, it was lost, buried by Slavic traditions and Slavic culture. We don't owe anything to these Scandinavians, basically. Yeah, so as I understand it, that argument first developed in the 18th century against the backdrop
又晦涩难明的主题，但它在政治上也极具争议。因此，在苏联时期，曾有过激烈的争论，苏联国内曾出现过一种真正的运动——曾有过激烈的争论，苏联国内曾出现过一种真正的运动——宣称基本上，好吧，那里确实有一些斯堪的纳维亚人，也就是维京人，但他们并不那么重要，他们的文化印记很快就……你知道的，被斯拉夫传统和斯拉夫文化所淹没、埋没了。我们基本上不欠这些斯堪的纳维亚人什么。是的，据我所知，这种论点最早是在18世纪针对
of Peter the Great's kind of defeat of the Swedes. So obviously the Russians didn't want to think that, you know, the foundation of their kingdom was Swedish. And then again, isn't it right that it was the Nazi invasion that really turbocharged this idea? Because Hitler said that without, you know, the Norsemen going in, the Russians would be living like rabbits or something. Exactly. So this is sort of, there's obviously a Germanic aspect to kind of Norse culture. They're very closely related. And so in the 20th century, it became really important for Stalin to sort of say, you know, no, we don't know. I think because the story is often told with kind of Viking overlords, as we'll go on to describe, Viking overlords, in inverted commas, civilizing the Slavic tribes. And obviously, if you are a
彼得大帝击败瑞典人的背景下发展起来的。因此，俄罗斯人显然不想让人们认为，他们的王国的建立是瑞典式的。然后，纳粹的入侵是不是真正给这种观点火上浇油了？因为希特勒说过，如果没有诺斯人（Norsemen）的介入，俄罗斯人就会像兔子一样生活，诸如此类。没错。所以这里显然存在一种与诺斯文化相关的日耳曼因素。它们联系非常紧密。因此在20世纪，斯大林表态变得非常重要，他要说，不，我们不知道。我想，因为这个故事经常被讲述为带有维京霸主色彩——正如我们接下来要描述的那样——带有引号的维京霸主，在教化斯拉夫部落。显然，如果你是一个
very keen Slavophile, if you're a kind of Slav nationalist, that's very offensive, the idea that you needed to be civilized by kind of Vikings in horned helmets, which they obviously didn't wear, in their long boats and whatnot. But of course, I mean, if you come from Britain, actually, the perspective you have on the Vikings is that this civilizing process, by definition, I mean, it's incredibly brutal that acknowledging the influence that Vikings, you know, have on 9th, 10th century Europe, whether it's in Britain or whether it's in, you know, the lands of the of the Naipa and the Volga. This isn't necessarily a civilizing process. It's a process of kind of conquest and brutalization well i mean the the really interesting thing is that these these two things are happening in parallel so everybody think when
坚定的斯拉夫亲善者（Slavophile），如果你是一个斯拉夫民族主义者，这种想法会非常冒犯：即你需要由戴着带角头盔（他们显然并没有戴）、开着长船之类交通工具的维京人来教化。但当然，如果你来自英国，你对维京人的看法实际上是，这种教化过程，从定义上讲——我是说，这是极其残酷的——承认维京人在9、10世纪的欧洲（无论是英国，还是第聂伯河和伏尔加河流域）所产生的影响。这不一定是一个教化过程。这是一个征服和野蛮化的过程。嗯，我的意思是，真正有趣的是，这两件事是同时发生的——所以每个人都在想，当
they think of the vikings i mean basically pretty much every primary school in britain as far as i can tell as the vikings at some point kids dress up in viking outfits and they put on horned helmets and they learn about dragon proud long boats and. But they almost always study it in terms of a story that the Vikings first pitch up at Lindisfarne. They sat in the monastery, and then they're constantly attacking England and France and Spain. And Alfred burns his cakes. There are a series of battles.
他们想到维京人时，基本上英国几乎所有的小学，据我所能了解到的，在某个阶段都会学到维京人，孩子们会穿上维京人的服装，戴上带角头盔，了解龙首长船等事物。但他们几乎总是通过这样一个故事来研究它：维京人首次在林迪斯法恩登陆。他们袭击修道院，然后不断攻击英格兰、法国和西班牙。阿尔弗雷德烧了蛋糕。有一系列战役。
The Vikings said, you know, it's all the West, and then expeditions to Greenland and Iceland. But actually, a lot of Viking historians, Neil Price, for example, would say actually what the Vikings are doing in the West is a copy. They're copying what they've already started doing in the East. And it's the story in the East that is more exotic, more exciting, and also, crucially, I would say, more lucrative.
维京人说，嗯，全都是西方的事，然后是对格陵兰岛和冰岛的远征。但实际上，许多维京历史学家，比如尼尔·普莱斯（Neil Price），会说维京人在西方做的事情实际上是一种复制。他们在复制他们已经在东方开始做的事情。而且发生在东方的事，是一个更加异国情调、更加刺激，而且至关重要的是，我认为也更加利润丰厚的故事。
There's so much money for a Viking to make sailing to the East rather than to the west and and you could argue that in the long run couldn't you tom creating russia it's quite quite a big big thing crane yeah and ukraine right well the issue of which of those can lay claim it's a bit like the greek the argument we had in alexander the great podcast about greece and macedonia and north macedonia as it's now called fighting over over the legacy of Alexander the Great, isn't it? Yeah, because this stuff really matters. Yeah, they both see themselves as the heirs of the Kievan Rus civilization. Yeah, so we've, I mean, the Vikings are such a great topic. We've both, I wrote about them in
维京人去东方航行比去西方能赚到多得多的钱，从长远来看，你也可以说，汤姆，创建俄罗斯，这可是一件相当了不起的大事，克林，是的，还有乌克兰，对吧？至于其中哪一个可以宣称拥有这份遗产，这有点像我们在亚历山大大帝播客中关于希腊和马其顿（现在被称为北马其顿）争夺亚历山大大帝遗产的争论，不是吗？是的，因为这些东西真的很重要。是的，他们都将自己视为基辅罗斯文明的继承人。是的，所以我们，我的意思是，维京人是一个太棒的话题了。我们俩都，我在
Millennium, I wrote about the Vikings in the East, you were writing a children's book about the Vikings right now, so you're absolutely kind of immersed in this. It's such a great topic. And we've done one episode already on the Norse epics, which essentially took us from Iceland to Greenland to Vinland and the New World. But even in Iceland, they are writing epics about what the Vikings are getting up to in the lands of the East, going down the rivers to Baghdad, the capital of the greatest empire on the face of the earth, to Miklagard, the golden city of Caesar, Constantinople.
《千年》（Millennium）一书中写过，我写过东方的维京人，你现在正在写一本关于维京人的童书，所以你绝对沉浸在其中。这是一个如此宏大的主题。我们已经做过一期关于诺斯史诗的节目，它基本上把我们从冰岛带到了格陵兰岛、文兰和新世界。但即使在冰岛，他们也在写关于维京人在东方土地上所作所为的史诗，他们顺流而下到达地球上面积最大的帝国的首都巴格达，到达凯撒的黄金之城君士坦丁堡——米克拉加德（Miklagard）。
And as you say, it's a story that is very, very thrilling because you have the same, you know, obviously the idea of of taking ship and discovering north america i mean that's an incredible story but so also is the idea that that people are going from scandinavia and kind of pitching up in baghdad you know or even further afield i mean it's it is an astonishingly romantic narrative well the before we get into the the um the sort of the narrative of it i mean the best example of that and the one that most, certainly British listeners and maybe English speaking listeners will know, everybody knows the story of 1066, certainly in Britain they do, the Battle of Hastings, Harold and William. But obviously there's a battle before that against a guy called Harold Hardrada, who comes over from Norway to try and claim the English throne.
正如你所说，这是一个非常、非常扣人心弦的故事，因为你有相同的——当然，乘船并发现北海的这种想法，我的意思是这是一个不可思议的故事，但同样不可思议的是，人们从斯堪的纳维亚出发，一路闯进巴格达（你知道的），甚至去到更远的地方，我的意思是，这确实是一个令人惊叹的浪漫叙事。嗯，在我们进入它的叙事之前，我的意思是，最好的例子，也是绝大多数英国听众、或许还有英语听众都会知道的例子——每个人都知道1066年的故事，英国人肯定知道，黑斯廷斯战役，哈罗德与威廉。但显然在那之前还有一场战役，是对抗一个叫哈罗德·哈德拉达（Harold Hardrada）的人，他从挪威渡海而来，企图争夺英格兰王位。
And the life of Harold Hardrada is this whole business in microcosm. Yeah. You know, he had been in Norway. He ends up going to Kiev. He ends up going to Constantinople and commanding the Imperial Bodyguard. He may have gone to Sicily. He may have gone to the Holy Land. You know, this is incredible.
而哈罗德·哈德拉达的一生就是整个事件的微缩版。是的。你知道，他曾在挪威待过。他最后去了基辅。他最后去了君士坦丁堡，并指挥皇家卫队。他可能去过西西里。他可能去过圣地。你知道，这太不可思议了。
The Princess. Well, these incredible adventures, many of which are unquestionably true because they're backed up in kind of, you know, Byzantine sources. So, I mean, you think about that life. He had a more interesting, well-traveled life than probably most of our listeners, certainly than us. Yeah, definitely. Well, so we've got from Mary Kirk Alves, who asked very simply, why were the Vikings going east? Was it more of an expedition or a conquest?
这位公主。嗯，这些不可思议的冒险经历，其中许多无疑是真实的，因为它们有（你知道的）拜占庭史料的支持。所以，你想想他的一生。他过着比我们的绝大多数听众、当然也比我们更精彩、游历更广的人生。是的，绝对的。好吧，所以我们收到了玛丽·柯克·阿尔维斯（Mary Kirk Alves）的问题，她非常简单地问道：维京人为什么要向东走？这更像是一次远征还是一场征服？
So obviously the geography of Scandinavia, kind of, you know, the ancients thought of it as an island. They didn't realise it was a peninsula. So you can take ship and go west across the North Sea or into the Baltic, up the Gulf of Finland. And beyond the Gulf of Finland lies the vast expanse, basically, of Eurasia. And the Vikings knew it as Sweden the Great, Sweden the Cold, a land of giants, of dwarves, of dragons, of men with mouths between their nipples who never spoke but only barked so an intimidating place but a place that as it turns out with incredible courage with incredible fortitude with incredible daring can lead you to the richest lands on the face of the planet the lands of of the caliphate and of the byzantine empire yeah that's right and i think um
所以很显然，斯堪的纳维亚的地理环境，古代人认为它是一个岛屿。他们没有意识到它是一个半岛。因此，你可以乘船向西穿过北海，或者进入波罗的海，顺着芬兰湾向上。在芬兰湾的那头，基本上就是广袤无垠的欧亚大陆。维京人称之为伟大瑞典、寒冷瑞典，这是一片充满巨人、矮人、巨龙、乳头之间长着嘴、从不说话只会吠叫的人的土地——所以这是一个令人生畏的地方，但事实证明，只要有难以置信的勇气、难以置信的坚韧、难以置信的大胆，它就能通往地球上面积最富饶的土地：哈里发国和拜占庭帝国的土地。是的，没错，而且我认为，
if you think about the geography so if you live in nor, if you live on one of the fjords or something, when you look out, you see the North Sea and beyond it, very rich kind of farmlands of England and the monasteries of Ireland and so on, and that's the way you go. But obviously if you live in Sweden, you're looking out east, southeast, and the first thing you see is an island called Gotland. Have you been to Gotland, Tom? I have. Have you? Yeah, I have. I went there on holiday a couple of years ago. Absolutely amazing place, beautiful island, fantastic churches, where Rachel Morley would
如果你考虑地理因素——如果你住在挪威，如果你住在某个峡湾之类的地方，当你放眼望去，你会看到北海，在它对面是英格兰非常富饶的农田、爱尔兰的修道院等等，这就是你走的路。但如果你住在瑞典，你显然是向东、东南眺望，你看到的第一座岛屿叫做哥特兰岛。汤姆，你去过哥特兰岛吗？我去过。你去过吗？是的，去过。我几年前去那里度假。绝对是个神奇的地方，美丽的岛屿，梦幻的教堂，雷切尔·莫利（Rachel Morley）会
enjoy it. But also coin hordes, these incredible hordes of coins, thousands and thousands of Arabic dirhams that have come up the rivers. So basically what you would do, if you were an entrepreneurial eighth century Swede, you would go to Gotland and that's the sort of staging post where you maybe find people for your crew or you sign on with somebody. And then obviously the place to go from, I mean, you know, England or France, they're not really on your radar.
喜欢那里。而且还有投币窖藏，这些不可思议的硬币窖藏，数以千计从河上运来的阿拉伯迪拉姆。所以基本上，如果你是一个有进取心的8世纪瑞典人，你会去哥特兰岛，那是你的中转站，你可能会在那里为你的船员找人，或者与某人签约。然后很显然，你要去的地方——我的意思是，英格兰或法国，并不真在你的雷达范围内。
What you do is you keep going across the Baltic. And there, as you say, you get the mouths of these rivers. And you know that somewhere at the end of that river is one of the richest cities on earth, Miklagard, Constantinople. And beyond it, it's all the wealth of the caliphate. And you have, I think there are two things, crucially, that you have, if you're Scandinavian, that they will buy from you. one of them is furs which you can kind of pick up on the way and the other crucially is slaves so this is a real a massive slave trading enterprise
你要做的是继续穿过波罗的海。在那里，如你所说，你会到达这些河流的入海口。你知道在那些河流的尽头，坐落着地球上最富有的城市之一：米克拉加德，君士坦丁堡。而在它之外，则是哈里发国的全部财富。我认为，如果你是斯堪的纳维亚人，有两样东西至关重要，他们会从你这里购买：
yeah it it absolutely is um and i think that um i mean let's so how do you get there if you're on you know if you're in sweden so there's um there, as you say, and there's this place called Birka, which is, I think, just west of Stockholm now. Been to Birka, Tom. And it's as close to a town as you get in kind of early 9th century Scandinavia. And from these kind of centres, you can head eastwards, up the Gulf of Finland. And there's the Volkov River. Yeah.
其中之一是你在路上可以收集到的毛皮，而另一个至关重要的则是奴隶——所以这是一场真正的、大规模的奴隶贸易企业。
And there's a town, Stara Ladooga. Yeah, Stara Ladooga, Tom. Is that how you pronounce it? You're Russian, it's shocking. Yeah, okay. So this is a kind of – well, it's not Wild West, is it? It's Wild East. Well, Neil Price has a lovely thing in his book,
嗯，这绝对是，而且我认为——我的意思是，让我们来看看——如果你在瑞典，你要怎么去那里？所以那里有，如你所说，有一个叫做比尔卡（Birka）的地方，我认为它大概在现在斯德哥尔摩的西边。汤姆，你去过比尔卡吗？它可以说是9世纪初斯堪的纳维亚最接近城镇的地方。从这些中心出发，你可以向东进发，顺着芬兰湾逆流而上。那里有沃尔霍夫河。是的。
The Children of Ash and Elm, where he says it's basically Deadwood. So, you know, it's sort of saloons. But I think a couple of people, he's not the only person to have made that American analogy, because Tom Shippey in his book, Laughing Till I Die, about the Vikings, he has a nice section about how, he says, you you know the way you to answer mary kirk's question it's not really like the kind of raids on linda's farm and stuff
还有一个城镇，旧拉多加（Stara Ladoga）。是的，旧拉多加，汤姆。你是这么发音的吗？你懂俄语，这太令人震惊了。好吧，所以这是一个——嗯，这不是蛮荒西部，对吧？这是蛮荒东部。好吧，尼尔·普莱斯在他的书
he says the way to think about it is about trappers and traders in north america with fur i mean the parallel is paddling down these rivers and there are sort of there are indigenous people tribes on either side sometimes they'll trade with them sometimes they'll kind of fight each other and that's sort of that's the and even the topography you know it's very heavily wooded lots of rivers lakes and things so you start off in storia ladiga and you kind of and that's kind of expanding as time goes and i think that's found in about 750 753 or something and then and then you go south don't you pick your river and you're kind of yes because what what the what the vikings are
《灰烬与榆树之子》（The Children of Ash and Elm）中有一段精彩的描述，他说这基本上就是《朽木》（Deadwood）。所以，你知道，这有点像酒吧。但我认为有几个人——他不是唯一一个做出这种美国式类比的人，因为汤姆·希佩（Tom Shippey）在他关于维京人的书《笑到死》（Laughing Till I Die）中，有一段很好的章节探讨了——他说，你知道，为了回答玛丽·柯克的的问题，这其实并不太像对林迪斯法恩之类的突袭，
bringing is the technology that enables them to navigate these rivers um and and that's evident i think even in the name right i mean that's so um there was a a message from um tapani simajoki friend of the show uh a finn um and he says an interesting tidbit on the linguistics of the east vikings and finland is the brackish meeting point of eastern west the finnish sweden ruotsi is probably derived from the same root as russ russlagen and russ so russlagen russ is rowing lagen is kind kind of the band, isn't it? So the land of the rowers. And that idea of ships going down rivers, people rowing often against the current, with the current.
他说，思考这个问题的正确方式是把它看作北美洲从事毛皮生意的猎人和商人——我的意思是，这种相似之处就在于划着独木舟顺流而下，两岸有土著部落，有时他们会和他们做生意，有时他们会互相打仗，这就是——甚至连地形也是如此，你知道的，那里树木极其茂密，有大量的河流、湖泊等等。所以你从旧拉多加开始，然后你——随着时间推移，规模不断扩大，我认为那是大约在750年或753年左右建立的——然后你向南走，对吧？选择你的河流，然后你——是的，因为维京人
And the ships are sufficiently, you know, they're built so that they can negotiate quite shallow waters and they're sufficiently light that, you know, you get to a lake, you need to go across to the head of a river, you can carry the ship. Yeah, but that's also where the slaves come in very handy. you get to the end of your bitter river or you get to the point where you need to cross over and basically you need to be able to get out either semi-dismantle your ship or or the ship is light enough to to for you to carry it or your slaves to carry or your slaves well this is where the slaves basically your cargo are carrying it for you i mean that's the sort of genius if you like the sort of horrific genius of the business model that you're trading human beings who are doing a lot of the work for you. And so, and so obviously there's, there's incredibly, you know, you're very vulnerable if you're having to carry a ship, you know, up mountains and, you know, where the rapids
带来的是使他们能够在这些河流中航行的技术，这一点即使在名称中也很明显，对吧？所以——有一条来自塔帕尼·西马约基（Tapani Simajoki）的信息，他是节目的老朋友，一个芬兰人。他说了一个关于东方维京人语言学的有趣冷知识：芬兰是东西方的咸水交汇点，芬兰语中的瑞典语词“Ruotsi”可能源于与“Russ”、“Roslagen”和“Russ”相同的词根。在“Roslagen”中，“Ros”意为划船，“lagen”有点像队伍，对吧？所以这就是划船者的土地。这种船只顺流而下的理念，人们常常逆流或顺流而划船。
are or, you know, through forests or whatever. So you're, you're, you're very vulnerable. And so that, that's why along the length of these lakes, these rivers, at certain key points, you start to get more and more kind of forts, really. So Novgorod, I mean, you're the Russian speaker here, Dominic. That means new fort, doesn't it? So that appears on Lake Ilmen. That's right. And they called it Holmgard home guard i think didn't they
这些船只足够——你知道的，它们的建造方式使它们能够通过相当浅的水域，而且它们足够轻，以至于你到达一个湖泊时，如果需要走到一条河的上游，你可以把船扛过去。是的，但这也是奴隶大显身手的时候。当你到达河流的尽头，或者到达你需要过河的地方，基本上你需要能够下船，或者半拆卸你的船，或者船足够轻，能够让你把它扛过去，或者让你的奴隶扛过去，或者你的奴隶——好吧，这就是奴隶发挥作用的地方，基本上是你的货物在为你扛着船——我的意思是，这就是商业模式的那种天才之处，那种可怕的天才之处：你正在贩卖人类，而这些人正在为你做大部分的工作。因此，显然——如果你不得不扛着船走过山脉、急流所在的地方，或者穿过森林等等，你会变得非常脆弱。所以，正是因为这个原因，沿着这些湖泊、河流的长度，在某些关键点上，你开始拥有越来越多的堡垒。所以诺夫哥罗德（Novgorod），我的意思是，这里懂俄语的人是你，多米尼克。那意味着新堡垒，对吧？所以它出现在伊尔门湖畔。没错。他们称之为霍姆加德（Holmgard）——家园卫队，我想是这样的吧？
um the um the russ themselves little the little fort and it's sort of i think a lot of these forts kind of a very north american style they're kind of made of logs on there so everything in novgorod is is made of wood yeah everything even the kind of you know rather than paper they're writing on kind of bark and things um so they're not, so to answer, go back to Mary Kirk's question, is it a conquest? I don't think they think of it as a conquest because they're not interested in, you know, it's not a risk where they're interested in kind of capturing lots of land.
罗斯人自己叫它“小堡垒”。而且它有点——我认为其中许多堡垒具有非常浓厚的北美风格，它们是由原木建造的，对吧？所以诺夫哥罗德的一切都是用木头建造的，是的，甚至连——与其说是用纸，不如说是写在树皮之类材质上。所以它们不是——因此，为了回答玛丽·柯克的问题，这是一场征服吗？我不认为他们认为这是一场征服，因为他们对征服不感兴趣——这不是那种他们渴望占领大量土地的冒险。
What they're interested in is the route, is the river, and making money. And they establish the forts as kind of trading stations, basically. And you can imagine the kind of, I think Neil Price in his book has a little stuff about, you know, the scene. People drinking, probably lots of crime. Tinkling on the piano. Sassy, sassy madams. Sassy bar tarts. Yeah.
他们感兴趣的是路线，是河流，是赚钱。他们建立堡垒基本上是为了当作贸易站。你可以想象那种场景——我想尼尔·普莱斯在他的书中写了一小段关于这个场景的描述：人们在喝酒，可能有很多犯罪。钢琴叮咚作响。风骚的老板娘。风骚的酒吧荡妇。是的。
All that kind of stuff. Yeah, but that's the sort of atmosphere. And obviously, that's quite cosmopolitan in the sense that there are lots of these Scandinandinavians who are mostly i think swedes because that's obviously where where you come from um but there are also undoubtedly at this stage lots of slavs so even at this stage i think you've got the mix that that becomes russia the mix of scandinavian and slav yeah absolutely and um so so novgorod is it's a play i, it's very like a kind of Western. So you get lots of celebrated figures in the Norse epics, you know, when they're down on their luck, they go there and they kind of recruit men, you know, people to go off to Britain or, you know, attack Denmark or whatever.
诸如此类的事情。是的，但这就是那种氛围。显然，这在某种程度上是非常国际化的，因为这里有很多斯堪的纳维亚人，他们大多我想是瑞典人，因为显然那是你来的地方，但毫无疑问，在这个阶段也有很多斯拉夫人才。所以即使在这个阶段，我认为你也已经拥有了构成俄罗斯的这种融合体：斯堪的纳维亚与斯拉夫的融合。绝对是的。所以——所以诺夫哥罗德是一个地方——它非常像一个西部小镇。因此，你会看到诺斯史诗中有很多著名的人物，当他们时运不济时，就会去那里招募人手，去袭击英国或丹麦等等。
But at the same time, obviously, from Novgorod, you can cross the lake and you can then either uh get the Dnieper which will take you down to the Black Sea and from the Black Sea to Constantinople, Miklagard the great city uh or to the Volga which will take you to the Caspian Sea and from the Caspian Sea to Baghdad or to lands even kind of you know in in Central Asia. They attack Azerbaijan at one point maybe it comes down it's kind of incredible um so so Novgorod is the kind of, I guess, the meeting point of Scandinavia, Naipa, and the Volga. And if you're going the sort of the Western route, as it were, the route down to Miklograd, the next stop is what becomes Smolensk.
但与此同时，显然，从诺夫哥罗德出发，你可以穿过湖泊，然后要么选择第聂伯河，它会带你南下黑海，再从黑海到达君士坦丁堡——伟大之城米克拉加德；或者选择伏尔加河，它会带你到里海，再从里海到巴格达，甚至到达中亚的土地。他们在某个阶段袭击了阿塞拜疆，这可能传了下来，真是不可思议。所以——所以诺夫哥罗德可以说是斯堪的纳维亚、第聂伯河和伏尔加河的交汇点。如果你走的是所谓的西方路线，也就是通往米克拉加德的路线，下一站就是后来的斯摩棱斯克（Smolensk）。
So, I mean, these are, you know, if you think of a lot of kind of well-known russia western russian towns and cities they have routes along this kind of route or or indeed even further east along the volga so the smolensk is a place called um seems to be begun as a place called nezdovo and that's the confluence of the denipper and the Svinets River. And again, you know, it's the same sort of wild west kind of atmosphere. But it's like the tension is rising because you're about to approach, as you keep going south, you're going to approach these rapids, these very exciting rapids that bizarrely we know about
所以，我的意思是，这些——如果你想到很多著名的俄罗斯西部城镇和城市，它们都沿着这条路线有路线，或者沿着伏尔加河向东延伸。斯摩棱斯克是一个叫做——似乎最初是一个叫做涅兹多沃（Nezdovo）的地方，那是第聂伯河和斯维内茨河（Svinets River）的交汇处。同样，你知道，这是一种同样的蛮荒西部风情。但随着你继续向南推进，紧张局势正在加剧，因为你即将接近那些令人兴奋的急流——奇怪的是，我们通过这份不可思议的资料了解到了这些急流。你一定有很多资料。一个拜占庭皇帝，不遑多让。是的，他写了一本手册。是的，为了他的儿子，君士坦丁七世。生于紫衣。他被称为紫衣贵族。他为他的儿子罗曼努斯（Romanus）写了一份外交政策指南。
from this incredible source. You must have a lot of stuff. A Byzantine emperor, no less. Yeah, who wrote a handbook. Yes, for his son, Constantine VII. Born to the purple. He wrote Porphyrogenitus. He writes a foreign policy guide for his son, Romanus.
基本上，这就是你如何应对我们所有邻居的方法。我的意思是，这简直是一份能够保存下来的不可思议的政策文件。在书中他说：所以，你知道，罗斯人，这就是和他们打交道的规矩。他基本上解释并列出了整条路线。所以他说他们有这种特殊的船只，叫什么名字来着？Monoxala，单 keel（龙骨）船。所以基本上，他说在这个时候，他们乘坐的是那种一次性的船只，
Basically, this is how you handle all our neighbors. I mean, just an incredible kind of, almost like a policy document to have survived. And in it, he says, so, you know, the Rus, well, this is the deal with them. And he basically explains, sets out the whole of the route. So he says they have these special boats called, what are they called? Monoxala, single keel boats. So they're basically, he says at this point, they're in kind of disposable boats,
类似于小独木舟。他说，他们所有人会一起组成一个大舰队。而到了这个时候，你已经身处现在的乌克兰了。所以你正顺着河流穿过现在乌克兰的中心地带。而且这条河只有在夏天才能通航。基本上，你得不断下船，随着急流临近，奴隶们会为你把船扛过去，而且这些急流都有
kind of little dugout canoes. They all go together in a big flotilla, he says. And by this point, you're in what is now Ukraine. So you're going down the river through the center of what's now Ukraine. And the river's only navigable in the summer. And basically, you keep having to get out and as the rapids approach the slaves will carry your boats for you and the rapids all have
极好的名字。你知道所有这些急流的名字吗？是的，它们太可怕了，不是吗？其中有一个名字甚至刻在了哥特兰岛的碑文上，对吧？我不知道那件事。其中一个叫做“饮者”（The Drinker）。厄苏皮（Esupi），饮者。格兰德里（Gelandri），咆哮者。伊福尔（Iphor），永猛者。莱安蒂（Leanti），大笑者。诸如此类。所以这些不同的急流都有一些奇怪的名字，
excellent names do you know all the names of these rapids yeah they're terrifying aren't they and they and there's one of them appears on an inscription actually in gotland i think does it i didn't know that um one of them's called the Drinker. Esupi, the Drinker. Gelandri, the Yeller. Iphor, the Ever Fierce. Leanti, the Laugher. So on and so forth. So there's sort of these weird names for all these different rapids,
他们驾船通过了所有这些急流。但当他们顺流而下到这个阶段时，他们现在正在接近更像是国家和部落联盟的势力。佩切涅格人（Pechenegs）。所以有佩切涅格人。他们太可怕了。他们有点接近国家和部落联盟。佩切涅格人。所以有佩切涅格人。他们太可怕了。他们是一群游牧民族。
and they navigate all them. But by the point at which they're coming down, they're now coming close to what are more like states and kind of confederations of tribes. Petch and Eggs. So there's the Petch and Eggs. They were terrifying. They're kind close to what are more like states and kind of confederations of tribes. Petch and eggs. So there's the Petch and eggs. They were terrifying. They're kind of nomads.
他们现在已经从历史中彻底消失了，不是吗？我不知道。我的意思是，我认为他们成了鞑靼人或其他什么人。但你可不想被他们抓住。他们是游牧民族。好吧，他们会割下你的头，并把它做成高脚杯，不是吗？他们后来不是这么做了吗？
They've just vanished from history now, haven't they? I don't know. I mean, I think they became Tatars or something. But you wouldn't want to be caught by them. They're nomads. Well, they will cut your head off and they will make it into a goblet, won't they? Didn't they do that later?
正如我们在节目后面会发现的那样。这非常、非常像《血色子午线》（Blood Meridian）。所以他们会这么做。还有可萨人（Khazars），他们极其有趣。是的。是的。所以，他们——我的意思是，他们更往东一些，基本上是斯拉夫人和哈里发国之间的缓冲地带。
As we'll discover later in the show. It's very, very blood meridian. So they'll do that. And there's also the Khazars who are incredibly interesting. Yes. Yes. So they're, so, so I mean, so that they are further east and they're basically a kind of buffer between the Slavs and the Caliphate.
所以他们是游牧的突厥人，但令人惊叹的是，他们皈依了犹太教，这是一件非常独特的事情。好吧，他们是世界上唯一的犹太国家，不是吗？在罗马占领圣地与20世纪40年代末以色列国建立之间，这可真是一件了不起的事情。他们为什么会选择犹太教，汤姆？好吧，故事是这样的——这在后面我们讨论基辅皈依基督教时还会再次出现——
So they're, they're nomadic Turkic people, but they amazingly convert to Judaism, which is a distinctive thing to do. Well, they're the world's only Jewish state, aren't they, between the Roman takeover of the Holy Land and the establishment of the State of Israel in the late 1940s, which is just an incredible thing to be. Why did they pick Judaism, Tom? Well, the story is, and this again will turn up later when we talk about the conversion of Kiev to Christianity,
可萨人的首领向各个势力发送了信息，让他们派出一个基督教修士、一个犹太拉比和一个穆斯林学者来劝说他。最后获胜的是犹太人，也就是拉比。这也是一部精彩小说的主题，我想那是80年代初由一个叫米洛拉德·帕维奇（Milorad Pavic）的塞尔维亚小说家写的，书名叫《可萨辞典》（Dictionary of the Khazars），这是一部魔幻现实主义小说。非常棒。我强烈推荐。所以可萨人
the leader of the Khazars sends messages to all the various powers to send him a Christian monk, a Jewish rabbi, a Muslim scholar to go and persuade him. And it's the Jewish, it's the rabbi who wins out. And this was the subject of a fabulous novel, I think written in early 80s by a guy called Milorad Pavic, a Serbian novelist called Dictionary of the Khazars, which is kind of a magical realist novel. Very good. I highly recommend it. And so the Khazars
似乎以一种奇怪的方式皈依了犹太教。但这其实说得通，对吧？因为他们夹在两个敌对势力之间。是的，一个基督教帝国和一个穆斯林帝国。所以无论他们倒向哪一边，都注定难逃厄运——所以他们跳向了第三个方向，结果对他们挺管用的。我认为，起初——罗斯人的精力真正聚焦的目标其实是哈里发国，而不是拜占庭，因为这是一个绝对的——所以我们收到了
seem to, in a weird way, have become Jewish. But it sort of makes sense, right? Because they're stuck between two rival powers. Yeah, a Christian and a Muslim empire. So whichever way they jump, they're doomed doomed so they jump a third way and it kind of works for them and i think that um to begin with that that it's the caliphate that is really the focus of of the energies of the russ rather than byzantium because it's it's an absolute you know we've so we've got um lots of questions about silver so stephan yensen himself a viking why are there such enormous amounts of arab about silver. So Stefan Jensen, himself a Viking, why are there such enormous amounts of Arabian silver coins in Viking graves across Scandinavia?
很多关于白银的问题——比如斯特凡·延森（Stefan Jensen）本人就是一个维京人，为什么在斯堪的纳维亚各地的维京人墓葬中会有如此数量庞大的阿拉伯银币？真正吸引他们的是白银的数量。因此，起初我认为他们顺着伏尔加河下行的次数要比前往黑海的多得多。所以他们是朝着里海方向去的。因此他们必须与可萨人谈判。其中一些人肯定最终到达了巴格达。好吧，他们被白银吸引，但也受到奴隶市场的吸引，对吧？巴格达对奴隶的需求是无穷无尽的。
It's the volume of silver that is really attracting them. And so to begin with, I think they're going down the Volga much more than they're going down towards the Black Sea. So they're going towards the Caspian. So they have to negotiate with the Khazars. And some of them definitely do seem to have ended up in Baghdad. Well, they're drawn by the silver, but also by the slave markets, right? There's an inexhaustible demand for slaves in Baghdad.
绝对的，是的。而且，你知道，显然他们带来的奴隶本身就是奴隶，但他们也很可能是带着在更北边的其他突击行动中俘获的奴隶。所以有很多儿童读物。我的意思是，罗斯玛丽·萨特克利夫（Rosemary Sutcliffe）写过一本精彩的书叫《血仇》（Blood Feud），讲的是一个男孩的故事——我想是一个男孩——他在威塞克斯被俘。他们把他带到都柏林，带到那里的巨大奴隶市场，
Absolutely, yeah. And, you know, obviously they are bringing slaves who are slaves, but they also may well be bringing slaves that they've captured in some of their other raids further north. So there are lots of children's books. I mean, there's a wonderful book by Rosemary Sutcliffe called Blood Feud, where it's the story of a boy, I think it is, who is captured in Wessex. They take him to Dublin, to the great slave markets there,
他最终通过某种方式顺流而下，最终到达了君士坦丁堡。但显然他也有可能最终到达巴格达。而且，你知道，认为相当大一部分——可能有相当数量的斯堪的纳维亚人，甚至是斯堪的纳维亚人本身、英国人、法兰克人、爱尔兰人、斯拉夫人——一路走得那么远，这绝对不是不可能的。好吧，我认为——爱尔兰人、斯拉夫人一路走得那么远？好吧，我认为主要是斯拉夫人。而这方面的证据显然是：我们拥有“奴隶”（slave）这个词。我的意思是，这个词深深地烙印在英语中，也烙印在许多其他欧洲
and he ends up, one way or another, he ends up going down the rivers and he ends up in Constantinople. But obviously he could have ended up in Baghdad. And, you know, it's not impossible by any means to think of quite a lot of, you know, substantial number of Scandinavians, possibly Scandinavians themselves, English, Franks, Irish, Slavs, going down all that way. Well, I think, Irish, Slavs, going down all that way? Well, I think it is mainly Slavs. And the evidence for that is obviously the fact that we have the word slave. I mean, it's absolutely imprinted on the English language, and many other European
语言中。你读过迈克尔·麦考密克（Michael McCormick）的书《欧洲经济的起源》（Origins of the European Economy）吗？我没读过。这是一本——我的意思是，这是一本厚重的大部头。他的观点基本上是：不仅仅是阿拔斯哈里发国，还有北非和西班牙的穆斯林土地，在经济上都比欧洲先进得多，以至于欧洲唯一能提供的真的只有奴隶。因此，奴隶的主要提供者是奥托大帝（Otto the Great），比如，节目的老朋友。所以他——你知道，他们正在捕获
languages as well. Have you read, come across Michael McCormick's book, Origins of the European Economy? I haven't. It's a really, I mean, it's a massive book. And his argument essentially is that the caliphate in all, you know, so not just the Abbasid caliphate, but the Muslim lands of North Africa and Spain as well, are so economically advanced ahead of Europe that all that Europe can provide really is slaves. And so the main provider of slaves is Otto the Great, for instance, friend of the show. So he is, you know, they are harvesting
大量、大量的斯拉夫人，并将他们通过欧洲运往西班牙，再运往北非。维京人所做的是，他们前往最富有的——你知道的，伊斯兰世界的腹地，前往巴格达，正是这一点开启了白银的大量涌流，然后他们能够将白银带回来——而且，真正解释西方维京人战役节奏的也正是这一点，因为当也门和中亚的银矿枯竭时，他们便开始将注意力重新集中到英格兰，因为英格兰此时也拥有了一种高度基于白银的经济。是的，而且因为在某些方面这更容易——我的意思是，如果白银能够大量涌入，这比获得土地要来得更直接——
vast, vast numbers of Slavs, and they're being transported through Europe, down through Spain to North Africa. What the Vikings are doing is that they are going to the richest you know the heartland of the islamic world and going to baghdad and it's that that opens up you know the vast kind of stream of silver that they're then able to bring back um and and it's it's it's really that that um explains the rhythms of uh viking campaigns in the west as well because it's when the silver mines in uh in yemen and in central asia dry up that they then start to refocus their attention on on england which by this point also has a kind of very silver-based economy yeah and also because it's easier in some ways i mean if you can get silver flooding in that's that's more immediate than getting land
我的意思是，如果你能得到土地，英格兰的土地当然很好，但你是对的。我认为我们必须把东方和西方的事务看作是平行的。显然，每当东方路线由于某种原因被切断，或者贸易出现萎缩时，你就会看到西方袭击的某种加剧。无论如何，是的。你会看到西方袭击的某种加剧，无论如何，是的。好吧，但这只是——所以中亚的萨曼尼德埃米尔（Samanid emirs）发现了这些巨大的银矿——我想大约在890年代——也就是9世纪末，并在10世纪的上半叶，
i mean land is great in england if you can get it um but you're's more immediate than getting land. I mean, land is great in England if you can get it. But you're right. I think we have to see the East and Western things sort of in parallel. That obviously, whenever that Eastern route is kind of cut off for some reason or there's a diminution in the trade, then you see a kind of intensification of the sort of Western attacks. But anyway, yeah. see a kind of intensification of the sort of western attacks yeah but anyway yeah well but it's just it's just so you get that the samanid emirs in central asia discover these vast silver mines uh i think in kind of 890s so um end of the 9th century and over the the first half of the 10th century,
白银从那里如潮水般涌入。当然，这也是西方英格兰国家得以构建、展开对维京人反击的时期。所以阿尔弗雷德及其继承人。推测是因为，实际上，东方有太多的钱可赚，以至于那成了主要的关注点，然后大约在965年之后，东方的银矿枯竭了，因此——比尔卡在10世纪末被废弃，
silver is flooding in from there. And that, of course, is the period where in the West, the English state is able to construct itself, the fight back against the Vikings. So Alfred and his successors. Presumably because, actually, there's so much money to be made in the East that that becomes the main focus of attention and then after about 965 the silver mines in the east dry up and so uh burka gets abandoned
你开始看到维京人重新向英格兰移居，比如失国者埃塞尔雷德（Ethelred the Unready）和蓝牙哈拉尔（Sweyn Forkbeard）等等。所以，我认为这非常迷人——我们往往不会去想——你知道的，英国国家的崛起以及随后维京人的卷土重来，其节奏在某种程度上受到东方白银供应情况的制约。好了，我们先休息一下，汤姆，等《历史的余烬》回来后我们继续。我们正在讨论东方的维京人，接下来我们将谈论各种——坦率地说，是毛骨悚然的事情。说到毛骨悚然的事情，汤姆，正如公众所知，我们对大众意见非常敏感。我们是人民的播客。我们是人民的播客。
towards the end of the 10th century and you start to get vikings moving back towards england ethel red the unready and svain forkbeard and so on so i think it's it's it's really fascinating i mean we tend not to think of that you know that, the rhythms of the, you know, the emergence of the English state, and then the return of the Vikings, to a degree, is being conditioned by the availability of silver in the East. Okay, we'll just take a quick break, Tom, and we'll come back after the rest is history we are talking about the vikings in the east and we've got all kinds of um grues frankly gruesome stuff to come now talking of gruesome stuff tom um we we are very responsive as the public know, to popular opinion. We're the people's podcast. We are the people's podcast.
上周，我们发布了两期关于查理一世审判与处决的播客。它们引发了极其强烈的反响。你看到一些……我不想用“失控”这个词。我不知道“失控”是不是合适的词。有些人可能会说是“激烈”。我要说的是，激烈的反响来自某一个特定的人，我们在节目刚开始时还点名提到了他——卡普尔·洛夫特（Capple Loft），他在国王与女王世界杯期间就已经对我们不满了，
Now, last week, we released two podcasts about the trial and execution of Charles I. And they provoked a remarkably intense reaction. Did you see some of the... I don't want to say intemperate. I don't know whether intemperate is the word. Robust, some would say. I would say that the robust response came from one person in particular, who we actually name-checked at the start of the episode, Capple Loft, who had already got cross with us
因为我们没有把查理一世纳入我们的……他有前科。我相信他甚至发起了自己的竞争世界杯。是的，查理一世在其中表现得非常好。是的，因为他操纵了比赛。是的，他确实这么做了。非常斯图亚特式的行为。
during the World Cup of Kings and Queens, because we hadn't included Charles I in our... He had form. He had started his own rival World Cup, I believe. Yes, which Charles I did very well. Yeah, because he rigged the tournament. Yes, he did. Very Stuart behaviour.
非常斯图亚特式的行为。总之，卡普尔·洛夫特对我们的节目做出了回应，他说——这是他在推特上发表的一言论：“第二次尝试收听《历史的余烬》关于查理国王与殉道者审判的节目，但再次不得不愤怒地中途停下。每一个早已被彻底驳倒的、懒惰的清教徒和小辉格党（Whig）宣传都被毫无异议地老调重弹。”
Very Stuart behaviour. Anyway, so Capital Loft responded to our episodes by saying, and this was a tweet he put out, just made a second attempt to listen to the rest of his history on the trial of Charles, King and Martyr, but once again had to stop in anger. Every lazy bit of long since debunked Puritan and Whig propaganda is trotted out without challenge.
“谎言和半真半假的话俯拾皆是。卑鄙。卑鄙。”我的意思是，这措辞很强烈。随后引发了激烈的讨论。所以我看完那条推特就睡觉了，第二天早上醒来发现有几百条消息，大家都在为查理一世的事情互相攻击。特德·瓦伦斯（Ted Valence）教授——我认识29年了，曾是我们的嘉宾，我认识他时他还是个十几岁的少年，你敢信吗？——卡普尔·洛夫特对我说：“作为一个鲍德温和约瑟夫·张伯伦的崇拜者，你竟然能在17、20——17世纪的政治问题上错得如此离谱，这让我感到痛心。不过，至少你还没有像那个地狱猎犬瓦伦斯那样，对所有的道德和 decency（体面）彻底麻木。”所以，说实话，他对特德的评价相当准确。他确实是个地狱猎犬。他就是。总之，多米尼克，我的意思是，我们做过播客，涵盖各种主题——法西斯主义、共产主义、穆罕默德以及各种各样的事情。谁会想到，竟然会是查理一世这个人物——卡普尔·洛夫特称他为“殉道者查理国王”——引发了这一切……总之，鉴于我们是人民的播客，并且我们对那些深信不疑的信仰保持响应，我们已经邀请了卡普尔·洛夫特参加会员专属播客。
Falsehood and half-truth abound. Vile. Vile. I mean, that's strong. So there was then a huge discussion. So I went to bed having just seen that and got up the next morning to discover about several hundred messages, attacking each other about charles the first um so ted valence professor valence who i've known for 29 years was was a guest i knew when he was a teenager would you believe and um uh capel off said to me it pains me that as a fan
虘言与半真假乂充钃。可恶。可恶。我的意思是这很严刍。于是当时发生了一场巨大的讨论。我看到那些内容后就上床睡觉了，第二天早上起床发现有几百条惵息，关于查力一世互相贯力攻击，所以我认识了29年的教授泰德·瓦伦斯是一位嘉宾，我在他是个青少年时就认识他，你能信吗，然后卡彪夫对我说，作为一名粉丝
of baldwin and joseph chamberlain you can be so wrong on 20th 17th century politics though at least you're not quite as dead to all morality and decency as that hellhound valence so i mean to be fair he's nailed ted pretty well he is a hellhound he is so anyway but dominic i mean we've we've done um i mean we've done podcasts and all kinds of things we've done um fascism and communism and Mohammed and all kinds of stuff. And who would have thought that it would be the character of Charles I that would... Charles King of Martyrs, K. Poloff calls him. So anyway, this is by way of saying that because we are the People's Podcast and because we are responsive to deeply held beliefs um we have invited capital loft onto the members uh podcast
的麽德文和约翰·开布朗，你在20世縀及17世縀政治上环环着错，尽管你至少没有像那个地犱犬瓦伦斯那样对所有道德和体面毫无若惜，所以我的意思是公建而论，他把泰德评得很准，他确实是个地犱犬，他确实是此，然而多尼尼，我的意思是我们已经做过了，我的意思是我们做过播客和各种二标签的东西，我们做过法西斯主义、共产主义、穆默黗以及各种东西。谁会想到竞然会是查力一世的人格...查力数王烈士，卡波夫称他为数王。所以芽，这也就是说因为我们是人民的播客，并且因为我们对深刻的信仰会作出响应，我们已经邀请了卡出高来到会员播客
that goes out to uh the wangs as we like to call them the members of the resident history special club um and that will be going out uh tomorrow tuesday well indeed so if you are if if you're a member you've got that to look forward to um and'll be debating with him about our treatment of Charles I. What he sees, I think, is the cancer of wiggery that has eaten into The Rest Is History. If you're not a member of The Rest Is History Club, this is your opportunity, basically. You don't want to miss out on the big fight. It's massive. Yeah.
这个节目将会在周二，也就是明天推出，送给那些我们称为“旺族”的居民历史特别俱乐部的成员们。如果你是会员，你就可以期待这个内容了。我们将和他辩论我们对查理一世的处理方式。我认为，他看到的是那种已经渗入《历史的残余》的“辉格党史观”的毒瘤。如果你还不是《历史的残余》俱乐部的成员，这就是你的机会，基本上是这样。你不会想错过这场大战的。这太巨大了。是的。
It's the big sports event of 2022 so far. And you can sign up to that on restishistorypod.com. Excellent. So back to the Vikings. Who were not Whigs. Definitely not Whigs. Definitely immune from the taint of Whiggery, I would say, the Vikings. Possibly even more immune to the taint of Whiggery than Kappel Loft.
这是目前2022年最大的体育赛事。你可以在 restishistorypod.com 上注册。太好了。那么回到维京人。他们可不是辉格党人。绝对不是辉格党人。我觉得维京人绝对不受辉格党史观污染的影响。可能甚至比卡佩·洛夫特（Kappel Loft）更不受辉格党史观的污染。
That is saying something. So one last question on this issue of contacts with Baghdad, Tom. Diogo Morgado has an excellent question. Vikings and Arabs, clash of civilizations or trade-based contacts? Does Islam have any influence in the decline of Norse polytheism? Well, I don't have an answer to the second half. The first half, I would say, not really a clash of civilizations. I mean, we have some really, really interesting things
这话说得真对。关于与巴格达接触的问题，汤姆，我有最后一个问题。迪奥戈·莫尔加多（Diogo Morgado）提出了一个绝佳的问题：维京人与阿拉伯人，是文明的冲突还是基于贸易的接触？伊斯兰教对诺斯多神教的衰落有什么影响吗？嗯，前半部分我没有答案。后半部分，我想说，其实算不上文明的冲突。我的意思是，我们有一些非常非常有趣的事情
written by Arabs about the Norse and saying, you know,'re very dirty or they they have weird customs and so on maybe we'll come to that but i would say it's more trade fascination um exchange and so on but you'll have your own answer what do you think well i think um the question of whether visitors to the caliphate you know are influenced by muslim do do they become do some of them become muslim do they bring muslim brides back i mean the evidence so there's there's um the grave of a woman in sweden was found who had a a ring with um kind of invocation of allah yes on the ring yeah uh and various textiles have been found again with kind of uh quranic phrases woven into it um the woman herself seems to have have come from the islamic world whether you i
由阿拉伯人关于诺斯人所写的事情，他们说，你知道，“他们很脏，或者他们有奇怪的习俗等等”，也许我们会谈到这一点，但我会说这更多的是贸易、迷恋、交流等等，但你会有你自己的答案，你觉得呢？嗯，我觉得，嗯，关于去过哈里发国的人（你知道的）是否受到穆斯林的影响，他们有没有变成穆斯林，他们有没有把穆斯林新娘带回来？我的意思是，证据是——那里有——嗯，在瑞典发现了一个女人的坟墓，她戴着一枚戒指，上面有对真主的某种祈求，是的，戒指上有——是的，还有各种纺织品，再次被发现，上面编织着某种古兰经短语，那个女人本人似乎来自伊斯兰世界，不管你
mean whether whether the fact that you have quranic messages on your robes means that you've become a muslim i'm not sure about that so it's surely unlikely surely it's just high status luxurious well because famously also there's a buddha was found wasn't it in the grave and um that doesn't imply they're buddhists and they're a kind of the crazier from uh you know from ireland um they're basically kind of garnering loot but i would have thought it wasn't beyond the bounds of possibility that um the caliphs were kind of sending missionaries to try and convert some of these barbarians. That's what they were doing. So who knows? Who knows?
我的意思是，不管是你的长袍上有古兰经的信息，就意味着你已经成为了穆斯林，对此我并不确定，所以这肯定是不太可能的，这肯定只是高地位的奢侈品，因为众所周知，墓穴里还发现了一尊佛像，不是吗？嗯，这并不意味着他们是佛教徒，他们是一群来自，你知道的，爱尔兰的疯狂家伙……他们基本上是在搜刮战利品，但我倒觉得，哈里发们派遣传教士试图让其中一些野蛮人皈依，并非完全不可能。这就是他们当时在做的事。所以谁知道呢？谁知道呢？
It's a very kind of interesting question. But Tom, that raises a really, really interesting set of stories. So we do know that there are lots of people who are Arabs and are Arab messengers, envoys and so on. Ibn Rustah, for example, miss car wire um that i'm sure my arabic's not quite that good uh ibn kuradab hib um and apologies to listeners for the atonement doesn't have the courage to these fantastic arabic voice um voices but i do uh but the most famous one is ibn fadlan so ibn fadlan um is i mean this is the story that basically anyone who's interested in the vikings in the east is familiar with
这是一个非常有趣的问题。但是，汤姆，这就引出了一系列非常非常有趣的故事。所以我们确实知道，有很多阿拉伯人，也有阿拉伯信使、特使等等。例如伊本·鲁斯塔（Ibn Rustah），还有米斯卡·维尔（Miskawayh）——我确信我的阿拉伯语没那么好——还有伊本·库拉达兹比赫（Ibn Khurdadbih），对于没有勇气把这些美妙的阿拉伯语名字念好的听众，我向大家道歉，但我有。但最著名的是伊本·法德兰（Ibn Fadlan）。所以伊本·法德兰——我的意思是，这就是任何对东方维京人感兴趣的人都熟悉的故事。
he is a an envoy stroke missionary who was sent by the abbasid caliph al-muqtadir to go to the vulgar to the people who live on the bulgar who are turkic people called the bulgars so they're not the kind of slav bulgarians that we think of now they are they're living on the Bulgars. So they're not the kind of Slav Bulgarians that we think of now. They're living on the Volga in what's now Tatarstan. And Ibn Fadlan has been sent there basically as a diplomat, straight missionary, to build him a mosque. And when he gets there, he finds a load of Vikings.
他是一位特使兼传教士，被阿拔斯王朝哈里发穆克塔迪尔（Al-Muqtadir）派遣，前往伏尔加河，去拜访那些住在伏尔加河畔、被称为“保加尔人”（Bulgars）的突厥语族人。所以他们不是我们现在所想的那种斯拉夫保加利亚人。他们住在伏尔加河畔，也就是现在的鞑靼斯坦。伊本·法德兰被派到那里，基本上是作为一名外交官兼传教士，去为他们建一座清真寺。当他到达那里时，他发现了一群维京人。
Vikings, yeah. And he's quite struck by them, isn't he? I mean, he's quite impressed by them. He says they're as tall as date palms, blonde and ruddy. And he's quite struck by them, isn't he? I mean, he's quite impressed by them. He says they're as tall as date palms, blonde and ruddy. And he's very impressed by their weapons and their kit and stuff. But he's also, they are the filthiest of Alice creatures. They do not wash after shitting or peeing, nor after sexual intercourse, and do not wash after eating.
维京人，是的。他对他（她）们印象相当深刻，不是吗？我的意思是，他对他（她）们非常赞赏。他说他（她）们像枣椰树一样高大，金发红润。他对他（她）们印象相当深刻，不是吗？我的意思是，他对他（她）们非常赞赏。他说他（她）们像枣椰树一样高大，金发红润。他对他（她）们的武器、装备等等留下了深刻的印象。但他同时也发现，他（她）们是最污秽的造物。他（她）们拉完屎或撒完尿后不洗手，性交后不洗澡，吃完饭后也不洗手。
They are like wayward donkeys. Yeah. So he sort of thinks of them in a very, you know, they're barbarians basically to him, aren't they? They are in a kind of weird way, noble savages, I suppose. Impressive, tall, strong, self-confident and so on, but also weird and a bit unsettling. And he's obviously a really interesting guy because he's curious.
他（她）们就像任性的驴子。是的。所以他基本上是用一种——对吧——在他眼里，他（她）们就是野蛮人，不是吗？在某种诡异的意义上，我想他（她）们是高贵的野蛮人。威严、高大、强壮、自信等等，但也怪异、有点让人不安。而且他显然是一个非常有趣的人，因为他很好奇。
So he says, he hears that one of their chiefs has died and they're going to have this massive funeral. He's like, oh, can I come and... He makes the worst decision of his life. No, it's an amazing decision. He says, I'd like to come and watch. Yes. So in Baghdad, when the Vikings turn up,
所以他说，他听说他们的一位首领去世了，他们将举行一场规模宏大的葬礼。他心想：“噢，我能去看看吗……”他做出了他一生中最糟糕的决定。不，这是一个了不起的决定。他说：“我想去看看。”是的。所以在巴格达，当维京人出现时，
they pretend to be Christian and they have to do that because if you're a follower of the book, then you can get in by paying a kind of tax. Whereas if you're a pagan, you can't. The thing that's interesting about this burial is that it's unapologetically pagan. There's no pretense about it being Christian whatsoever. And the fascination of that for archaeologists is when they dig up the ship burials or whatever, and they find kind of various dismembered animals and the skeletons of women and things inside it. It's very difficult. You know, you've got the hardware, but you don't have the software.
他们假装自己是基督徒，他们不得不这么做，因为如果你是“书经人”，你就可以通过交某种税来进城。而如果你是个异教徒，你就进不去。这场葬礼有趣的地方在于，它是毫不掩饰的异教风俗。它根本没有假装成基督教的葬礼。对考古学家来说，其迷人之处在于，当他们挖掘船葬等遗址时，发现里面有各种被肢解的动物、女性的骨骼之类的东西。这非常困难。你知道，你有硬件，但你没有软件。
Ibn Fidlan's account provides the software that otherwise we simply wouldn't have. Yeah. And also he provides quite good ammunition for people who say when these guys went east they were still very much scandinavians because this is a scandinavian an identifiable scandinavian funeral ritual that is taking place i mean god knows how many hundreds of miles away on the volga in what is now the absolute kind of r heartland. And how long does it take, Tom? It takes 10 days, doesn't it? It takes 10 days to get ready for this funeral. I mean, it is the most colossal blowout, basically.
伊本·法德兰的记述提供了我们原本根本无法获得的“软件”。是的。而且，他还为那些认为“这些家伙去东方时仍然非常具有斯堪的纳维亚特色”的人提供了极好的弹药，因为这是一场斯堪的纳维亚风格的、可识别的斯堪的纳维亚葬礼仪式。我的意思是，天知道它是在伏尔加河畔、在现在绝对算得上是俄罗斯腹地的地方，距离斯堪的纳维亚有多少百英里。这花了多长时间，汤姆？花了10天，不是吗？筹备这场葬礼花了10天时间。我的意思是，这基本上是一场极其庞大的狂欢。
Presided over by a sinister old woman called the Angel of Death. I saw she was a witch, thick-bodied and sinister. It's a civil referred line. He's fattest unfortunately yeah he's not impressed by the angel of death at all i mean frankly with your name like that you're asking for oh for disobliging commentary but so yeah i mean it's um you wouldn't you wouldn't want i think to be a female slave um in the vicinity of the Angel of Death. You wouldn't.
由一个被称为“死亡天使”的阴险老太婆主持。我看到她是个女巫，身材粗壮而阴险。这真是个妙不可言的台词。他不幸胖乎乎的，是的，他对死亡天使完全没有好印象。说实话，顶着这样一个名字，你就是在自讨——呃——不受欢迎的评论。所以，是的，我的意思是，在“死亡天使”附近，你绝不会——绝不会——想成为一个女奴。你绝对不会。
That is for sure. So someone has to accompany the dead Viking chief to the afterlife. And so they ask for a volunteer. And actually, it doesn't have to be a woman. It could be a slave boy as well. But it's a girl who volunteers. So they've lined them all up, haven't they? And there's people. So the guy's ship has been propped up on the shore with wood yeah he's kind of half half buried is that right i think
那是肯定的。因此，必须有人陪同死去的维京首领前往来世。于是他们征求志愿者。实际上，并不一定非要是女性。也可以是男奴。但最终是一个女孩自愿报名的。所以他们把所有人都排成了一行，对吧？还有其他人。这个男人的船被木头支撑着放在岸上，是的，他被半埋了，是这样吗？我想
something like that it's a half buried yeah so it's half kind of they've they've they've hit earth over half of it so that you then go in that's right yeah the other half is outside they've they've they've divvied up his the dead guy fortune three ways. So a third of it is spent on booze, unbelievably. Which is great, isn't it? A third of it is spent on... Like kind of death duties. On special kind of funeral gear. So on other funeral stuff like his burial clothes.
差不多就是这样，这是一艘半埋的船，是的，所以它被——它们把泥土盖在了它的一半上面，这样你就可以走进去，对，是的，另外一半在外面，他们把死者的财产分成了三份。因此，其中三分之一令人难以置信地花在了酒上。这太棒了，不是吗？其中的三分之一花在了……类似于遗产税的东西上。花在了特殊的葬礼装备上。比如他下葬时穿的衣服等其他葬礼用品上。
And then the remaining third is split up among his heirs, basically. So there's this massive kind of festival atmosphere. And they get the slaves together and they say which of you volunteers and im fadlon watches kind of fascinated he's got an interpreter with him who's explaining what's going on and this girl steps forward she's a teenager i think it's pretty clear she's a teenager whether she is coerced or whether she steps forward voluntarily is unclear i would say tom but she she um having volunteered she's then treated like a kind of princess and she gets given slaves she has clothes and jewels and
然后剩下的三分因此分给了他的继承人们。所以这里有一种非常巨大的节日气氛。他们把奴隶们召集在一起，问他们谁愿意自愿报名。伊本·法德兰在一旁着迷地看着，他身边带着一个翻译，向他解释发生了什么。这个女孩站了出来，她是个十几岁的青少年，我认为很明显她是个十几岁的青少年。汤姆，她究竟是被迫的还是自愿站出来的，目前还不太清楚，但她——嗯——在自愿报名之后，她被当作公主一样对待，她得到了奴隶，得到了衣服和珠宝，以及
she gets given kind of drugs i think and it's kind of weird thing where she she goes to something that that looks like a doorframe that's on the last day isn't it um so on the last day, isn't it? Yeah. So on the last day, the 10th day, they set up a sort of a bed on the deck of the boat with this guy's presumably by now in quite putrid, rotting corpse in bed, dressed in these fancy clothes. And they lay out a huge feast around his body. Then they bring out the girl. The girl by now has been clearly, she's been very heavily drugged and given booze and stuff.
她得到了一些药物，我想，这是一个很奇怪的事情，她走向了看起来像是门框的东西，那是最后一天，对吧？——嗯——所以是在最后一天，对吧？是的。所以在最后一天，也就是第十天，他们在船的甲板上搭了一张床，上面躺着这个家伙的尸体——到这个时候，尸体想必已经相当腐烂恶臭了，身上穿着华丽的衣服。他们在他的尸体周围摆放了一场盛大的宴会。然后他们把那个女孩带了出来。此时这个女孩显然已经被喂了大量的迷药、酒之类的东西。
Then they bring a dog to the ship and they cut a dog in half, the dog in half. And they throw both halves of the dog on board. I mean, so strange. They put all the guy's weapons in the cabin. They tear the heads off some chickens yeah even fat line at this point is thinking god this was a very bad decision but the weird
然后他们把一条狗带到船上，把狗劈成两半，把狗切成两半。他们把狗的两半都扔到船上。我的意思是，太奇怪了。他们把那家伙的所有武器都放进了船舱。他们扯下一些鸡的头——是的，伊本·法德兰此时在想，天哪，这是一个非常糟糕的决定，但奇怪的是
what's this funeral the door frame yeah they lift her up they lift her up and she says she can see her father and her mother then they lift her up again and she sees all her family and then the third time she says that she sees her master in the afterworld and it's green and it's beautiful and there are all kinds of yeah then they they take off her jewels and they she walks onto the deck of the ship this is a weird detail she walks on the raised palm so she's being held up in a sort of you know mosh pit style scenario they hoist her onto the ship um she sings a leave-taking song and then they make her drink two big kind of flasks of of beer i assume or yeah or something um and then at this point so even fadlan at this point his story which is pretty dark becomes
这是什么葬礼，门框啊？他们把她举起来，他们把她举起来，她说她看到了她的父亲和她的母亲；然后他们又把她举起来，她看到了她所有的家人；然后第三次，她说她在来世看到了她的主人，那里一片翠绿，非常美丽，还有各种各样的——是的。然后他们脱掉她的珠宝，她走上了船的甲板。这是一个奇怪的细节：她踩着高举的手掌走上去，所以她被以一种类似（摇滚音乐会里）人头攒动的形式托举着，他们把她 hoisted（吊起/抬上）船——嗯——她唱了一首告别歌，然后他们让她喝了两大瓶——我猜是啤酒，或者——是的，或者是某种饮料——然后在这个时候，伊本·法德兰此时的故事，原本就挺黑暗的，变得
genuinely very dark because he says at this point she's confused and she's crying out and she doesn't want to carry on or whatever but the angel eight yeah the angel of death at this point grabs her and sort of they drag what they do they drag her into a little cabin at this point everybody's on that side they're allming. Beating on their shields. Beating on their shields. It's such a terrible scene. To drown out the screams that she's giving. And then four of the men hold her down,
真的非常黑暗，因为他说，此时她很困惑，在哭喊，她不想继续下去了，诸如此类。但那个——死亡天使，是的，死亡天使此时抓住了她，他们把她——他们做了什么？他们把她拖进了一个小船舱里。此时所有人都在那一侧，他们都在狂欢。敲打着盾牌。敲打着盾牌。这真是太可怕的场景了。为了盖过她发出的尖叫声。然后四个男人把她按倒，
and two others strangle her while the angel of death is stabbing her with a knife. Even Fadlana's watching all this, and one of the guys standing next to him says god you have terrible rituals in the caliphate don't you i mean compared with this this is brilliant you must be absolutely and you can sort of tell from his account that he's thinking this is this is pretty awful yeah um yeah it's a it's a really it's a really weird i think it's so weird isn't it it's such a weird story't it? It's such a weird story. And it's sort of, you get this so much from Neil Price's books,
另外两个人勒死她，而死亡天使则用刀刺她。伊本·法德兰目睹了这一切，站在他旁边的一个人说：“天哪，你们哈里发国的仪式真可怕，不是吗？跟这个相比，这简直太棒了。你一定感到非常……”你可以从他的叙述中看出，他心想：“这可真够呛。”是的。——是的，这真是一个——这真是一个非常诡异的——我觉得这太诡异了，不是吗？这真是一个诡异的故事！这真是一个诡异的故事。而且它给人的感觉是，你在尼尔·普赖斯（Neil Price）的书里能强烈地感受到这一点，
that our image of kind of Viking religion is all very kind of jolly. And it's kind of Thor and his hammer and Odin and all this stuff. But actually, this is the darkness. I'm not sure about that. I mean, all the main gods are kind of terrifyingly phallic. Yeah, but the way in which it's portrayed to children, Tom, and the way it's presented to the Marvel comics version of Norse mythology. But Thor, I mean, Thor is a serial rapist.
我们对维京人宗教的印象其实非常欢乐。什么索尔和他的铁锤啊，奥丁啊之类的。但实际上，这才是黑暗面。我对这一点持保留意见。我的意思是，所有主要的神明都具有可怕的男性生殖器崇拜色彩。是的，但这种形象被呈现给儿童的方式，汤姆，以及它在漫威漫画版的北欧神话中呈现的方式……但索尔，我的意思是，索尔是个连环强奸犯。
The Hammer is obviously very phallic. Odin is always raping. Yeah. Frey, I mean, he has the statue of him at Uppsala in Sweden he has an absolutely enormous phallus yeah it's unsettling I think and this story is incredibly
铁锤显然具有很强的男性生殖器象征。奥丁一直在强奸。是的。弗雷，我的意思是，他在瑞典乌普萨拉的神像上有一个绝对巨大的男性生殖器雕塑。是的，我觉得这挺让人不安的。而这个故事简直是
it's unbelievably rich and interesting for historians, archaeologists anthropologists and so on because it makes sense of a lot of the burials that you find across the Viking world the corpses of animals exactly of the burials that you find. Or the kind of dismembered corpses of animals. Yeah, exactly. And the weird things you find.
对于历史学家、考古学家、人类学家等来说，它极其丰富且引人入胜，因为它解释了你在整个维京世界发现的许多墓葬现象。动物的尸体——没错——你所发现的墓葬。或者被肢解的动物尸体。是的，完全正确。以及你发现的那些奇怪的东西。
But it gives you a sense of, you know, the sort of the jolly adventure story in Rosemary Sutcliffe kind of way in which so many of these Viking stories are told actually misses out just how cruel and violent a world and strange and and unsettling a world it was anyway well i you know and i think i think that um you know you know what i'm going to say now that um it's about the the conversion of the vikings to christianity is it removes them from a world that i think to us is unimaginably strange. Yeah. Because we remain in the,
但它让你感受到，你知道的，罗梅里·萨特克利夫（Rosemary Sutcliffe）小说里那种快乐的冒险故事风格——许多维京故事都是以这种方式讲述的——其实忽略了这个世界是多么残忍、暴力、怪异和令人不安。无论如何，好吧，我知道——而且我想——我想——你知道我接下来要说什么了，那就是——关于维京人皈依基督教这件事，它将他们从一个我认为对我们来说极其陌生的世界中剥离了出来。是的。因为我们仍然生活在
in the kind of the, the moral ethical world that Christianity gave, gave us, you know, or, you know, Islam as well. I mean,
基督教赋予我们的那种道德伦理世界里，你知道的，或者说，伊斯兰教也是如此。我的意思是，
they're, they're, you know, Ibn Fadlan sense of, of kind of the sense of the strangeness and the horror of it is, is to that extent hours. And that world to us, I think is very, very remote ours and and that world to us i think is
他们，他们，你知道的，伊本·法德兰对那种陌生感和恐怖感的体会，在某种程度上也是我们的体会。而那个世界对我们来说，我认为是非常非常遥远的。我们的世界和那个世界，我认为
very very remote and difficult and strange and and weird and so the process by which um the russ end up becoming christian is very very kind of important uh as that passage from from putin that i read at the start of this episode okay well i think i think that that's enough for today's episode and and clearly we we thought we were going to get all this done in one episode. We're not. I think that tomorrow we should go to the Dnieper, we should go to the founding of Kiev, we should look at in a bit more detail the relationship of the Rus to Constantinople and the process by which the Kievan Rus became Christian. So we will see you back tomorrow. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常非常遥远、艰难、陌生、诡异，因此罗斯人最终皈依基督教的过程非常非常重要——就像我在本集开头读到的普京的那段话一样。好吧，我想今天的节目就到这里了，很显然，我们原本以为可以在一集里讲完所有这些内容。我们没有。我想明天我们应该去第聂伯河，去看看基辅的建立，更详细地了解罗斯与君士坦丁堡的关系，以及基辅罗斯皈依基督教的过程。所以我们明天见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。